whoa be honest okay we appreciate your
call this afternoon and it appears we're
going back live now to the printers row
book fair richard Pearlstein is the next
author he'll talk about President
Richard Nixon thanks for your call
right right good afternoon everyone and
welcome to the 24th annual Chicago
review and coroner's row book there my
name is Michael Dijon and I'm the
communications manager for the Chicago
Tribune we'd like to thank all of you
for supporting Chicago Tribune's
commitment to literacy and we'd also
like to thank the sponsor of today's
program to freedom Museum which is
located at the base of the historic
Tribune Tower in downtown Chicago and
it's the only Museum in the country that
is dedicated to freedom and the and the
First Amendment if you'd like to know
more about the freedom museum you can go
online at freedom museum us today's
session will be broadcast live on c-span
to his book TV and we ask that you use
the microphones located at the center of
the room during the Q&A session toward
the end so that our home viewing
audience can hear your questions and
with that I'd like to now introduce to
you Chicago Tribune's literary editor
love Elizabeth Taylor welcome and thanks
so much for being here Rick and I are
just going to talk our conversation and
then we will look forward to questions
so China Nixon Watergate Vietnam ring
with Agnew
Kissinger this guy does everything ah so
you know a lot of books about Nixon but
one reminded one that wasn't wrote
written and Nixon quipped you know my
mother was a saint and no one wrote a
book about her but within this or so
many books about Nixon written by Garry
wills Elizabeth drew Roberts dalek it
goes on and on so the bar is really high
when it comes to anything new to say but
with Rick
Nixon land Rick Pearlstein offers a
fiercely original approach to Nixon and
it's not a con cradle-to-grave biography
which sort of begins with California and
a meager Quaker roots and then ends up
to this exile and dimension New Jersey
so reposting offers through and he also
resists this idea of sort of lots of
detail sort and then dressing up the
detail in a little suit with a little
CSIS on it on what he does is something
very original and different he looks at
the relationship between Nixon and sort
of the youth counterculture of rebellion
and authority there's a tech cinematic
feel to the book and as the title makes
clear it's not intended to be a straight
biography of Nixon but sort of a rather
sort of story of America kind of
channeled through one of America's most
studied and and yet still lucemon and
exotic public figures um Nixon Landers
sort of a pull up a chair and to let me
tell you these stories approach to the
late 1960s and early 70s and
characters character Richard Dickson
there appears la like sort of throughout
look and it's it's remarkable that tries
to submissive sort of understand our
past and sort of so many of us probably
in this rooms who grew up in this period
and it really makes us sort of rethink
really think we think that past Rick we
were just talking of and sort of earlier
and I just coming down here nick is very
detail you've ever forgotten this guy
just remember everything you could
possibly think and I remember um
although you know like he never
remembers like things like he writes for
The Tribune often and he never remembers
to fill in his forms or send anything
back or you know the copy is always
perfect but there's those like little
forms and stuff that you know I still
need them Rick you're like you don't I
got rent to pay well I hope we're not
depending on that meager a fever book
review anyway so the details in this
book so tell me you know tell me about
the Renaissance bookstore the fur coming
of age and sort of how you came to this
book you mentioned the Renaissance
bookstore I did I grew up in Milwaukee
Wisconsin about two hours north of here
and the story I've been telling over and
over again on the radio is when I get my
driver's license when I was 16 instead
of chasing women or I don't know going
to trying to get into bars I was driving
to the Renaissance book store in
downtown Milwaukee and if any of you who
have been there there were nice outpost
at the airport it's this five or six
story ramshackle derelict firetrap
little warehouse still around on
plankton Street where they just have
piles and piles and piles of old books
and that was my my playground that was
my
paradise I would get crazy old books
from the sixties which which soon became
my obsession like the Marxist minstrels
about how the Beatles were a communist
plot for a look out honking Black Power
is going to get your mama by Julius
Lester the Black Power writer who's now
a conservative for that excuse but why
do people believe the way they do why
did this strange phenomenon of the 60s
visit itself upon America when it did so
close to our own time why was there this
this bizarre civil war but the best part
of the Renaissance bookstore is the
basement which is full of magazines and
if you were moving you know to Florida
say or Arizona and you had to get rid of
your boxes of boxes of Reader's Digest
or Time magazine's or ramparts their
life you take them down to the
Renaissance bookstore and they just
dumped them in the basement so I would
sit there just read and read and read
old magazines and see this unbelievable
human pageant of cacophony unfold
America's 1960s and eventually that
became my life's work putting that
putting those threads together I'm
asking those details in a way that made
them intelligible the Stewart to make a
sort of pattern of this do you describe
Nixon and as the have you described
Nixon as in this great phrase as the
serial collector of resentments is a
wonderful phrase and it's also made me
think of the part of the book of Nixon
in Chicago and in particular this one of
my favorite parts of the book can you
tell the story of a box
7:22 sure I just wrote a post in my blog
which is at our future org and in honor
of Barack Obama's imminent nomination
and it will kind of
how far have we come as a nation kind of
reflection and I immediately thought
back to the day I was at the Chicago
Museum of History which used to have the
much more poetic name the Chicago
Historical Society I think they should
change it back don't you and I was
studying in the Paul Douglas papers Paul
Douglas was a beloved senator from
Chicago who was up for re-election in
1966 a beloved liberal one of the kind
of architects of the New Deal stalwart
civil rights supporter his wife who had
also been a congresswoman marching arm
and arm and Selma with Martin Luther
King and he was up for election the same
year that Congress was considering the
first civil rights bill that affected
the north as much as it did the south it
was going to have an open housing
provision it was going to make it
illegal not to be able to it was going
to make it illegal to not rent your home
to someone or sell your home to someone
on the basis of race Paul Douglas was a
huge supporter the guy who ran against
Charles Percy started out as a supporter
but he kind of followed the Republican
line and eventually kind of became an
ambivalent critic of it Martin Luther
King was in Chicago marching for open
housing what he would do is they would
go to a real estate agent on the
southwest side of Chicago in the
bungalow Belt and they would bring a
couple and say you know we wanted to buy
a home and they would be politely and
enthusiastically shown you know 20 or 30
houses and the bungalow Belt then they
would bring in a black couple and yeah
as hell I'm sorry we're out of houses
you know no houses today you know so
just this one real state and see they
found you know 20 or 30 prima-facie
violations of this because this was
against Chicago law the chicago open
housing ordinance so Martin Luther came
to make a long story short decided to
march through these neighborhoods to
dramatize those problems and of
basically one of my favorite stories in
the book is quite tragic is the March on
August 5th where Martin Luther King
literally had a softball-sized rock
thrown at his head and you know that
that got it knocked him to the ground
and someone tried to throw a knife at
him and people held up swastika black
cards you know right here in our own
Chicago 10,000 people they they they
they wheeled the marchers cars into the
Marquette Park lagoon box 72 72 in the
Paul Douglas papers is all the letters
that Paul Douglas got from his Chicago
constituents about these housing marches
and it is the most astonishing x-ray of
a profound political shift in America in
which voters who had been kind of
enthusiastic Democratic voters and New
Deal voters rejected liberalism rejected
the Democratic coalition because they
were supporting this hope and housing
law and the letters are absolutely
astonishing Emma can I read about
they're still moving yes I would like to
know if this Martin Luther King is
President of the United States
why should Chicago be the harassment for
all the Negro ills and problems from
wherever they come do something senator
to clip his wings this is one from a 38
37 West 65th place 64th place you know
something if that madman King and his
bunch tried to pull off this in Russia
they would be shot the first thing in
the morning they would never stand for
what he is doing and you know it as well
as I do why not tap them all off for
Russia
this is unbelievable this is from 45 76
south mozart all handwritten letters you
know it's my firm belief and all of my
neighbors that king should be taken into
custody charged with fomenting civil
disorder and anarchy or at the very
least enjoined from any further marches
into the white community with the avowed
purpose of proving that he is beyond the
law which all the rest of us must obey
today the inseparable arrogance of this
character places him on a pedestal as a
dark-skinned Hitler now we enjoys Martin
Luther King Day and everyone thinks that
Martin Luther King was this you know
beloved figure but he was he was a very
frightening figure to most Americans
maybe just one more am i living in
Germany under Hitler's rule or America
as I recall past it comes to mind that
Hitler sent troops to march in the
streets of Germany this display of power
frightened the people and they ran to
their homes to hide is this what we were
being told told today when Hitler pardon
me I mean Martin Luther King decides he
and his troops want to harass an area he
calls a march of power and our
politicians send the storm troops
correction police and National Guard
helped frighten the people of the area
when greedy mr. Hitler started taking
over other countries people at first dot
give him a little more than he'll be
satisfied given greedy mr. King a little
more freedom than he will stop isn't
that what we are being told as I'm
sitting there in the Chicago History
Museum reading these things this became
one of the hinges of my narrative this
became part of the story I tell on Nixon
land which is a book about how basically
voters like these gave Lyndon Johnson a
land fly election in 1964 and gave
Richard Nixon a landslide election in
1972 on a platform of backlash against
things like the civil rights movement
and the anti-war movements and all the
cultural and social changes that were
genuinely baffling horrifying
frightening to kind of ordinary
middle-class Americans and their
reaction was sometimes
hateful but sometimes was was quite
legitimate and and and often was
patronized and condescended to by the
Liberals of the day who never really had
an answer to why the crime rates were
exploding and what the government could
do about it things like that so
basically my book is a story of how
liberalism gave way to this fearful
reaction against liberalism by 1972 and
the story it tells is ones like this in
Chicago or two years later the Chicago
Convention in which you know anti-war
protesters and police
you know clashed in the streets or 1970
when four protesters were killed Kent
State and and 62% of Americans in a
Gallup poll thought they had it coming
you know things like that
so when we think about 1968 and the
election you think of things like Oh
Bobby Kennedy's campaign in California
there's you movies about it but it seems
that this groundswell of its
conservative dimension was really
overlooked so why was why did history
over look at why well the same day you
know 40 years ago this week that you
know Bobby F Kennedy Bobby Kennedy was
won the California primary and then was
shot that same day a guy named Max
Rafferty won the Republican Senate
primary he was a very strange very
far-right guy who basically was one of
the first guys to say we shouldn't be
teaching about evolution in the schools
you know the the dictionaries are full
of swear words in the school libraries
and he beat a very popular liberal
Republican senator named Tom Kegel but
we don't remember that because of the
the drama of Kennedy and the
assassination but in many ways since of
the guy who was the governor of
California then Ronald Reagan would be
President the United States
twelve years later with the same
coalition that that you know
that max Rafferty won the primary with
oh by the way max Rafferty lost the
general election and the reason he lost
was because a week before the election
it was discovered that he dodged the
draft during World War two so he was
going around you know talking about the
hippies and the anti-war protestors and
victim I mean the story of the freedom
movements and the liberal ascendancy of
the sixties is one of profound drama
and it's one we should be telling I mean
it really is like an exodus narrative I
mean it's an extraordinary movement in
which a country change in ways both for
the better and ways that were very
frightening to a lot of people and the
people who kind of told a sixties
history for most of our most of our
lifetimes have been sort of veterans of
those freedom movements and I first kind
of became aware in the middle of the 90s
and that was of editor of magazine
called lingua franca that scholars who
were post baby boomer who were born you
know after after these events had
happened like I was born in 69 I like to
say that you know I made a bigger mess
in 1969 and even Richard Nixon had but
done the scholars were seeing things
through a different set of eyes with a
different perspective seeing a lot more
kind of state continuities between the
62b left and earlier social change
movement seeing the religious roots of
the new left but most of all of seeing
that the real lasting structural
transformation American politics in the
1960s was the rise of this conservative
coalition that looked at the changes the
changes of the 60s in a kind of a
fearful and wary way and in Richard
Nixon rose on those feelings of fear and
dread that he shared so the sense this
is sort of the second book of your kind
of life work this is sort of the second
book of of Rick's sort of life work of a
look at the 60s and 70s his first book
was before the store
armed barry goldwater and unmaking of
the american consensus and obviously
nixon the subtitle licks and land the
subtitle the rise of a president and the
fracturing of america which leads me to
the question sort of what about
consensus is you know what's so great
about consensus i'm not an organic
consensus actually consensus is a word
that was very big in the 50s and the
early 60s and it was meant to describe
what supposedly America had achieved
we've been through the depression we've
been through a world war two and we had
basically the New Deal this idea that we
are going to sort of you know utilize
the state to try and stabilize the
economy and and basically provide
guarantees of well-being to average
Americans seem to have become
institutionalized when Dwight Eisenhower
became president in 1953 there was a big
question was where the Republicans going
to try and roll back the New Deal well
no it turned out that Dwight Eisenhower
actually institutionalized the New Deal
and if anything sometimes expanded it a
little a built the interstate system the
idea that we had reached the center-left
equilibrium was very much a very much
intellectual fashion of the day and
believe also that there was no serious
there's no serious contender that
conservatism had had outlived its
usefulness and in the 1964 election
which I wrote about in my first book
before the storm Barry Goldwater was the
Republican nominee and he was the guy
who would oppose a civil rights act and
he posed Social Security you know he
opposed the New Deal he wanted to
rollback the New Deal and he was handed
an overwhelming defeat Lyndon Johnson
who had you know passed this you know he
passed Medicare he'd passed the civil
rights bill won 61% of the vote you know
he want every state except for Arizona
and five of the southern states so it
really seemed that to the pundits that
conservatism
was superseded by something else
and this just amazing quotes from
pundits Lyndon Johnson spent 65 the year
1965 passing again more social
legislation more civil rights
legislation than Voting Rights Act and
Scotty Reston of the New York Times said
the only thing he hasn't passed is
outlawing the Republican Party but he
haven't tried that yet so Lyndon Johnson
in 1964 when he's right right lighting
the White House Christmas tree after
this landslide election the month before
says these are the most hopeful times
since Christ was born in Bethlehem in
August of 1965 he signs the Voting
Rights Act
you know the witch redeemed the martyrs
of Selma and he says the slaves came
here in Chains we finally have broke
those fierce and ancient bonds it really
seemed to be a liberal apotheosis well
five days later the Watts Riots began
covered live on TV by America's first
news helicopter you know kind of
narrated like this kind of demonic
play-by-play and suddenly the idea that
we were in the midst of a consensus no
longer made sense anymore people were
rioting in the streets and the question
that fascinates me is why did these
pundits think that America was so united
in a peaceful itself in the first place
and what are my answers that they kind
of systematically repressed all evidence
to the contrary in 1964 when Lyndon
Johnson won that huge victory he won
California by a million votes but that
same day California had a more had a
referendum on open housing the same
issue that Martin Luther King was
fighting for in Chicago
and they voted against open housing by a
million votes no one talked about these
contradictions no one talked about the
fact that you know we had a foreign
policy that was about to collapse on
itself in Vietnam in fact I have a
friend the the Chicago Los Angeles bass
talk radio host Michael Jackson
who tried to talk about watts on his
radio show he was the most popular radio
host in Los Angeles and he was fired
because they didn't want him to talk
about wives and from this kind of raw
material I was kind of built up a
working thesis in American history that
this whole idea of repressing underlying
conflict American life is just a big
part of how we do politics in America
and that it's not a good thing it's a
dangerous thing and I use the example
sometimes of the Civil War where prior
to the Civil War as the sectional crisis
is gathering steam as we're heading
towards a blood bloodbath the slaughter
of 600 600 thousand Americans how does
Congress deal with this mounting crisis
they pass a gag rule they make it
illegal for congressmen to even talk
about slavery this repression of the
underlying conflict that often makes the
conflict more passionate and more
hateful and more violent when it does
come and you see it today you know when
you're not allowed to talk you know
allowed to say we might be in a
recession you know you're not allowed to
say that there are racial problems in
America and if you bring that up then
you maybe you're an elitist or something
like that
so this bit migrans being say it and
it's a fact interesting theme do you
mentioned about the pundits so I love
the pundits love the Thunder they're
always wrong and you know what they're
still around and they're always long ago
well I was some of these characters in
Nixon land to endure still and I would
Roger Ailes for instance talk about
people love to hear my Roger Ailes
that's a great story in fact I mean not
a lot of people know the guidance
started Fox News was basically Richard
Nixon's achieved television propagandist
for the 1968 presidential election and
he started out he's very young one of
the things people were obsessed with in
the 60s was the youth the idea that the
youth were was this new left-wing force
in American culture well you know what
it was also a conservative force to
Roger Ailes
was younger than Abbie Hoffman he was
younger than Tom Hayden and he was the
guy who told Richard Nixon let me back
up
Nixon was going on the Mike Douglas show
which was an afternoon show kind of
watched by housewives and he was sitting
in the makeup chair and this young
producer named Roger Ailes 26 years old
making small talk Nixon says you know
isn't it strange it wasn't a strange the
things you have to do these days to
become president in United States go on
these silly you know afternoon chat
shows were housewives and rather than
kind of humoring him Roger Ailes fixed
them in the eye and said if you think
this is silly you'll never become
president of the United States and
immediately delivered a detailed
critique of all the mistakes Richard
Nixon had made in a television campaign
in 1960 when Roger Ailes had been in
high school now Roger Ailes long story
short went to work for Richard Nixon in
1968 the story is told brilliantly in
Joe mcginnises classic book of selling
at a president she invented the fake
town hall meeting where they would get a
bunch of ordinary citizens ask Nixon
questions there will be a bunch of
Nixon's fans and the audience whenever
he says the fans of the Nixon people
would wait ecstatically applaud and so
they would cut this into 30-second
commercial so it looked like the whole
whole country was going gaga over
Richard Nixon and Roger Ailes was the
guy who started a fair and balanced Fox
News and so you might know the back
story about Roger Ailes
let me just one more question and then
sub questions and you'll have to walk up
to the microphone for those but you
close your book with this line we're
living in Nixon land still can you just
talk about that a little bit that's been
an interesting kind of invitation to
debate people it's been controversial a
lot of people took me when you write a
book like this you candid in the editor
says great you know cut it by 20% and we
need a preface in the conclusion you
know so people know what it's about and
and then people review the preface in
the conclusion especially that the the
AM radio hosts you go on who haven't
read the book asked you about are we
living in Nixon land still you know a
distinguished scholar like Elizabeth
Taylor assets stat but one way in which
this was interpreted was saying that the
violence and passion in our politics are
just as great as they were in the 1960s
when people literally were shooting each
other in the street and that's certainly
not the case but my argument is that the
terms that Richard Nixon forged in or
just describe the reality of the 60s
basically became the terms in which we
describe our political reality right now
the way he talked about how liberal
elites were looking down their noses at
you and me and the way he talked about a
law-and-order it's still the template
for how the Republicans described
politics now and by the way Nixon land
also refers to the kind of tension that
liberals sometimes speak of when they
speak of ordinary Americans desire for
just reasonable bourgeois order so we
still seem to be fighting our political
battles using the same language
bequeathed to us by Richard Nixon around
Reagan in the 60s even though the
reality on the ground
is truly a lot less contentious and I
wrote those words at the end of 2007 and
sometimes I feel like that famous line
from Hegel the owl of Minerva flies at
midnight we're only able to understand a
period kind of as where as we're leaving
it and sometimes I wonder whether we are
not entering a new way of thinking about
our cultural politics
I mean I'm fascinated by the example of
this special election in Mississippi
about a month ago
in which the Republican ran the same
Republican campaign they always run they
put on scare TV commercials saying as
the Democrat refused to denounce Barack
Obama for his his hateful anti-american
preacher you know the Democrat refused
to denounce Barack Obama for his claim
that rural people are bitter and Clint
cling to guns and gays it was the same
campaign we've seen from the Republicans
since 1972 running against Abbie Hoffman
you know running against Oakland
Carmichael and this is in Mississippi
and the moral of the story is lo and
behold the Republican in Mississippi
lost by seven points in a district where
George Bush had won by 10 points in 2004
so the idea that these political habits
given to us by the 60s and by Richard
Nixon and especially in the 1972
election might be being superseded is
something I'm kind of entertaining I'm
not really sure yet yesterday sitting
this chair Rick segments and I'm a
historian and I don't like to make
predictions so I'm not going to make any
predictions but it's a very fertile and
fascinating historical time and it's
been a very fertile and fascinating time
to revisit the period that I have to
begin to think about of the changes we
may or may not be facing now questions
please come up to the microphone or
shout them out now Gordon the microphone
for the TV yeah please
surely there are questions ice I have
three concerns one you say rapidly lost
because he dodged the draft
well Clifton Bush and Cheney went to
office having dodged the drag how do
what happen well what World War two what
was a very popular war and the Vietnam
War was a particularly unpopular war so
there are qualitatively different
situations Oh certainly I use it the
Nixon rose on the on the kneel on the
Conservatives were against open housing
but people who have examined the
election of 1968 closely Senate it is
impossible to tell who won the election
but I can say that the only winner was
Henry Kissinger because kids there was a
candidate of both parties not a temple I
was described where let me let me speak
to that member someone else yeah
microphone the the coulomb it was a very
very close election in 1968
fascinatingly so Richard Nixon was
elected with only like 43% of the vote
but there was a third candidate George
Wallace and George Wallace was kind of
defined the right word fringe of this
backlash politics I talked about he was
a horrifying scary figure almost a
fascist figure he would speak to a crowd
of 10 or 20,000 people and you would say
well we don't have riots in Alabama when
people start rioting me to shoot him in
the head he get a standing ovation he
got 12% of the vote so if you add up
Richard Nixon's vote and George
Wallace's vote you basically get a
landslide that this kind of anti-liberal
backlash politics and this is very
important because as Kevin Phillips
argued in this book for 1969 this shows
that there's an emerging Republican
majority
and basically one of the dirty tricks of
the Watergate period when Richard Nixon
was president was that he he he
fundamentally he bribed George Wallace
bye-bye basically dismissing a Justice
Department charge against his brother
Gerald into running as a Democrat
so basically Richard Nixon was able to
harvest that 12% of the vote that had
gone to George Wallace in 1968 for
himself and when is 61% 49 state
landslide for many reasons but one of
them because he had monopolized the
backlash vote so anyway maybe the next
guy
the next question yeah comment I'm
interesting that for the Washington Post
that George wills actually reviewed your
book and I thought that was probably
yeah an interesting discussion inside of
the editorial office sex and you can
comment on that the second thing is
though is that something that also I
think we've inherited from Nixon land is
the notion of the imperial presidency
and I think the sense is the the Nixon
people were actually inside of the
administration were actually enables
okay but they knew they were criminals
okay I think they also moved into the
Reagan administration as well and they
to many cases knew they were criminals
made me but the possible possible
exception of Ollie north who was of
course as a textbook paranoid
you know they had comments on his
medical records were expunged actually
the salesmen well yeah it gets the the
Kissinger question the very first
executive order that Richard Nixon
signed during the inaugural parade
basically eliminated the parts of the
State Department that checked the power
of the National Security Council so
economic history became a very powerful
the most powerful National Security
Adviser so basically together with
Richard Nixon made foreign policy kind
of in this potent plan potentially way
within the White House without much
without basically any any oversight I
mean people would learn about you know
the Secretary of Defense will learn that
they were bombing Cambodia by reading
about it in the newspaper things like
that you know Congress didn't know
anything about the fact that we invaded
Cambodia until Nixon went on TV and
April thirtieth and said so the style in
which Nixon pursued the presidency
really brought to the fore people within
the Republican Party whose specialty was
skullduggery and chicanery and it did
become institutionalized in the
Republican Party in a fascinating way I
mean I was I was I was reading about
Fred Thompson's presidential campaign
went back when he had won about a year
ago and there was a quote from one of
his advisers by the name of Kenneth
reeds said ten three times I asked him
that name before and had looked him at
the use of the search function on my
computer and lo and behold he was the
guy whose job it was to pass off the
secret documents that they had stolen
from the Humphrey campaign in 1972 to
the White House on a corner on
Pennsylvania Avenue to a guy who was
known in the Watergate hearings only as
fat Jack so so and then and then so I
decided to do some research about this
ken Reed sky what happened to him within
the Republican Party that he could be
this distinguished figure in 2007 and
I learned that he'd been working for the
Republican National Committee in 1973
during the Watergate hearings when his
name came out the Republican National
Committee fired him because he was
implicated in some of this skulduggery
and he did land on his feet because by
1976 he was running Ronald Reagan's
California presidential campaign so
there's this very strange
institutionalization within the
Republican coalition of this kind of
Nixonian
imperial presidency of skullduggery and
I'm not sure of the conservative
coalition has reckoned with that has
thought through that has has redeemed
that so yeah it's a very important
problem another part of Nixon land is
the opening to China's Shanghai
communicator the entire width Russia
could you comment on some of those parts
of Nixon land please yes I there's a lot
to admire by Richard Nixon his courage
certainly his refusal to back down in
times of hardship I mean one of the one
of the things I can't believe about
Nixon is the way he faced down a mob in
Caracas Venezuela and you know 1958 and
walked into the mob and this is actually
improved earlier the stoning and crack
was later but you walked into the mob
and basically talked them down his
courage was incredible he he was
fascinated by the idea of remaking the
world into a system of alliances that
was stable and could last for the long
term without war now there was a lot of
violence in the event in fact when he
when he negotiated his opening to China
in 1971 his go-between was a guy named
general Khan who was the dictator in
Pakistan who was busy engaging a
genocide in Bangladesh and Nixon kind of
looked the other way because he needed
this guy general Khan to be his go
between but the opening to China was a
very brave and far-seeing act because
China was so isolated by the United
States in diplomatic circles that you
could be arrested if you went to a
Chinese opera before
in Canada I mean that's how that's how
it's like North Korea now and they said
only Nixon can go to China and emails
how that is if anyone else had had any
other president had had made an opening
of China Nixon would have read bata the
hell out as he did when the Kennedy
administration was talking about you
know giving Mongolia seat in the UN you
know Nixon said that that would you know
by the end of the world but he basically
saw in opening to China and negotiating
with the Soviets a way to end the
Vietnam War which was the great vexation
of his presidency he thought that since
the Communists in North Vietnam in and
the Viet vietcong insurgents were
sponsored by both China and Russia the
China Russia could pressure could kind
of compete for America's favor by
pressuring by pressuring the enemy to go
to the negotiating table now there's a
tragedy in that in that it overestimated
it underestimated how organic the the
forces in in Vietnam were how they
didn't need China and Russia to tell
them what to do so it's just one more of
these tragedies of our Cold War hubris
but by the same token it was it was it
was a very far seeing thing although it
wasn't so far seeing because in the
Shanghai communication the Shan
communicate which came out of Nixon's
February 1972 trip to China there's only
one sentence on trade because Henry
Kissinger told Nixon the amount of trade
I can imagine
America ever having with China is
infinitesimal
on that I know that we should be
concluding our sessions today thank you
so much for coming and yes in Rick will
be signing books outside so if you have
any further questions true enter them
there thanks for coming
[Applause]